bonsoir à tous bonsoir Annie Girardot
bonsoir je suis ravie de vous avoir avec
nous et je dirais ravier un double titre
d'abord parce que c'est vous et puis
parce que vous savez quand on fait une
émission quotidienne d'actualité
culturelles on reçoit des gens qui ont
une actualité alors les mauvaises
langues disent ahlala c'est de la
promotion et là voilà je voulais montrer
l'exemple d'une artiste qui vient qui
n'a rigoureusement rien à vendre il n'y
a pas de films qui sort votre livre ma
vie contre la tienne chez Robert Laffont
ça fait quand même quelques mois qu'il
est sorti donc voilà vous venez
gratuitement dans tous les beaux et sens
du terme oui parce que j'aime beaucoup
cette émission
d'après vous c'est si devenu si rare
finalement que ben voilà on puisse se
rencontrer comme ça sans
qu'effectivement la promotion ou la
nécessité de service
c'est surtout les chanteurs
je sais que souvent je faisais des
émissions et je demandais un chanteur de
venir il m'a dit ah non c'est pas
possible je n'ai rien à vendre en ce
moment c'est à dire j'ai pas de disque
si complètement dément mais l'acteur non
je veux dire ils peuvent venir
comme ça je veux dire un acteur ça passe
partout puisque un chanteur pour la
télévision évidemment c'est en ce moment
évidemment on voit les chansons on
entend et tout voilà mais nous non alors
on a évoqué il y a quelques semaines
avec un vraiment très très beau moment
d'émotion avec Jean Marais Jean Cocteau
mais j'avais envie de vous en faire
parler puisque Jean Cocteau et quelqu'un
qui tout de suite vous a reconnu une
vraie valeur en disant vous aviez un
tempérament dramatique hors pair je
voudrais raconter une histoire très
drôle il avait dit paraît-il un nijardo
c'est le plus beau tempérament
de la prière et je suis allé il y a un
an et demi deux ans
à Bratislava au Tchécoslovaquie enfin on
se Slovaquie puisque maintenant et alors
donc on m'a présenté comme ça et on m'a
dit alors voilà Annie Girardot c'est le
plus beau tempérament de l'après-midi
j'avais une erreur de traduction oui
sûrement je sais pas
laquelle des deux formules préférées
françaises et je jouais les sous-brets
bon comme avec Belmondo d'ailleurs lui
il jouait
voilà et puis brusquement
étant entrer la Comédie française comme
comme soubrette évidemment et Cocteau
ils ont meilleur m'ont demandé de jouer
la machine à écrire Margot de la machine
à écrire de Cocteau alors évidemment
j'ai connu cet homme fabuleux drôle mais
que j'ai ri avec lui vraiment et puis
et puis d'avoir connu je veux dire j'ai
eu une chance extraordinaire parce que
je les connais tout de suite après j'ai
connu Visconti avec marais voyez venons
j'ai fait le et en même temps Piaf voilà
j'ai connu c'est
c'est c'est de bons hommes et cette
bonne femme en plus alors ce regard
finalement d'amour et de reconnaissance
donc octo bénéficie aujourd'hui alors
que Dieu sait qu'il a été vilipendé au
moment c'est quelque chose qui vous
réjouit qui vous c'est une sorte de
justice qui lui est rendue d'après vous
bah moi je trouve que c'était évident
qu'on lui donne justice maintenant mais
il a toujours eu non il a écrit
finalement beaucoup plus fort
mais mais pas Cocteau je veux dire la
façon qu'il est réflexions qu'il avait
c'est pour ça j'ai eu un plaisir à
écouter Jean en parler parce que j'ai
même passé une soirée avec lui il y a
quelques temps où il parle de lui mais
c'est une merveille déjà Jean déjà c'est
un c'est un spectacle c'est un homme
hors du commun mais en plus parlons de
Cocteau il le parle en plus avec
tellement de gentillesse tellement
d'humour de simplicité moi je trouve que
c'était
enfin tous les deux étaient formidable
je veux dire je trouve qu'ils se sont
voilà des personnes qui se sont
formidablement apportées et en même
temps tellement différent mais mais
c'est très beau d'entendre gens encore
parlé de lui comme il en parle vous
évoquez vice-comté vous avez revu Rocco
et ses frères qui est quand même le film
les gens indéfiniment le film légendaire
dans lequel vous avez tourné bien sûr
récemment je l'ai revu il n'y a pas très
longtemps il y a dû passer il y a
quelques mois enfin je ne sais plus donc
même assez c'est prêt moi je me souviens
plus enfin bref et je vois ce film je
sais pas qui passait et c'est mon frère
qui regarde alors bon j'ai regardé Rocco
je vous jure moi je fume beaucoup j'ai
pas fumé je suis resté debout devant ma
télé et je savais que ce film était beau
mais quand on voit à la fin quand il a
des frères dit au petit il lui dit tu
verras un jour
on retournera au pays et je me souviens
à ce moment-là quand je l'avais vu quand
j'avais vu le film à ce moment là
j'avais pas vu depuis 18 ans et je me
dis donc ça m'avait fait beaucoup
beaucoup d'effets mais je ne savais pas
qu'il était aussi beau parce que tu sais
aujourd'hui que jamais on ne retournera
le pays mais c'est bien de le dire et
c'est ça le talent de viscontique et le
savait à ce moment-là et encore 33 ans
après on se dit toujours qu'on va
retourner au pays on y croit encore
alors que on y retournera jamais et quel
regard on a il est c'est un regard quoi
qui est plein de nostalgie aussi pour
plein de nostalgie oui oui bien sûr
parce que viscontin est parti parce
qu'il est agent sont partis vraie NATO
est parti je veux dire bon c'est pas
seulement la mort bon Cocteau est parti
je veux dire mais c'était
que le cinéma quand même on se marrait
bien je veux dire qu'on avait
aussi bien
en France en Italie je veux dire les
films étaient faits d'abord par des
producteurs et les producteurs comme tel
que un qui viennent mourir d'ailleurs
qui est qui est mouchkine
et
dauphins
on prépare un film pendant 3 ans enfin
je sais pas eux alors il y avait des
auteurs ou réécrivait le film on ne
savait pas pierre pro le savait on
prenait bon tel mais l'enseigne qui
prenait tel acteur et puis c'était la
joie c'est d'une histoire d'amour on va
tourner un film c'était la joie voilà
c'est c'est plus rien c'est ça qui est
dramatique moi c'est ça qui me fait peur
parce que je me disais de couper le
retour parce que ça fait beaucoup de
bruit sur le plateau avant qu'il joue
merci
il y avait une joie une joie par exemple
quand on faisait les filles vous n'avez
peur alors
le jour de la sortie alors on allait
c'était le mercredi à l'époque où le
jeudi je me souviens plus et alors on
allait tous à 2h de l'après-midi sur les
Champs-Élysées et c'était un calcul
mathématique c'est-à-dire on voyait les
gens qui rentraient et tu savais ce que
faisait ton film ça ça continue oui
seulement maintenant on demande plus la
vie aux gens parce que maintenant on
fait un tel Boom Boom on en parle
partout à la télé tu vois moi
personnellement j'irai pas
personnellement tandis que on laissait
au public quand même bon je parle de
mourir d'aimer par exemple où je parle
de la vieille fille des films que j'ai
fait en fait tous les films que j'ai
fait et bien à ce moment-là les films
sortaient on avait quand même une
angoisse alors même s'il y avait des
critiques etc mais on laissait quand
même le choix au spectateur moi j'ai vu
comme ça par exemple
le grand blanc avec la chaussure noire
ou Z moi j'y suis allé là le premier
jour le deuxième jour il y avait une
cinquantaine de personnes
il pouvait venir il avait des films
d'ailleurs qui le plaisait et c'est
lui-même qui faisait le truc maintenant
c'est plus lui on lui demande plus son
avis vous avez été membre de jury de
sérieux parce que j'ai pas pu faire
autrement sinon on arrive c'était à
Berlin
alors j'étais même président du jury
parce que j'ai toujours peur parce que
c'est bon je suis toujours à droite à
gauche et c'est pas de ma faute mais je
suis demandé à droite à gauche bref
alors il m'est difficile alors après
j'ai dû aller quelque part mais à ce
moment-là je ne peux pas alors donc je
dis non tout de suite maintenant je dis
c'est fini je ne veux pas je n'ai pas
c'est pas que j'ai pas la patience c'est
que je n'ai pas de temps à donner comme
ça moi on m'en donne pas moi du temps
alors moi dans tout ce que je dois faire
il faut que je réponde à U à dire et
donc j'ai pas le temps en plus d'aller
si je tourne je peux pas quand même
aller je vis un film et donc si je veux
pas faire bien vaut mieux pas le faire
du tout vous avez une très grande
popularité en France on peut le dire
mais une popularité très singulière
c'est à dire ce que j'appellerai une
popularité de proximité dire que les
gens vous aiment bien par rapport à des
rôles de de qu'ils sentent très proche
d'eux quoi très ancré dans le dans la
vie quotidienne et je pense que c'est
très spécifique ça ait l'impression dans
le cinéma français mais j'étais parti de
la famille quoi mais je pense que ça
vient d'une chose
c'est que je pense être la seule comme
il y aide en tout cas en France avoir
interprété des des femmes
des femmes qui voilà une femme qui a un
cancer une femme une femme mère de
famille Inge etc je vous parle de taxi
je veux dire ah bon au cinéma où tu
avais la star ou tu avais
ou la [ __ ] ou je sais pas quoi ou la
femme trompée on fait un bon mais la
femme n'avait pas une place
prépondérande je pense que avec les
rôles qu'on m'a donné parce que on me
dit Oh là un tempérament même des des
des rôles d'hommes on me les a
transformés au féminin et donc j'ai au
lieu de jouer une directrice de galeries
ou non ce sont des femmes qui qui font
partie de
dans le quotidien et qui sont au cinéma
oui ça c'est vrai que je le fais
[Musique]